ist der lebende Beweis dafür dass in
Lenggries Integration gelingen kann
2015 floh er aus Eritrea nach
Deutschland ein langer Weg der hier ein
glückliches Ende fand fast ein Jahre
gedauert die Flucht von Ihrer Treppe ist
Deutschland war schwer aber
am Ende
seit fünf Jahren arbeitet viel Moor in
der Autowerkstatt von Andreas stöckner
der Kfz-Meister fand lange keinen
Auszubildenden und ist jetzt froh dass
er filmora hat
die Ferien kommen
und hat es im Kopf drin und das ist
einfach nichts mehr gehen
stöckner ist begeistert von seinem
Mitarbeiter aus Eritrea und dennoch
sagte er viel mehr Integration schaffen
wir nicht 100 km integriert
dann kommen Sie vielleicht ein bisschen
im Griff aber 100 Griff denn hier auf
dem Parkplatz direkt neben Stöcken das
Werkstatt soll eine Containeranlage für
100 geflüchtete entstehen Stöcken und
die gesamte Nachbarschaft sind sich
sicher dass geht so nicht in der
Integration in Containern
es ist vorauszusehen dass die 12 Jahre
in den Container bleiben oder Sie ziehen
heute an andere reden Bereich von Bayern
es ist doch egal ob man jetzt 100
Asylanten oder 100 deutsche in so einem
Containerdorf
mit wenig Aussicht auf Erfolg ohne
Arbeit sind die selten Probleme nur mit
dem Unterschied dass man sehr halt
versteht wenn sie fluchen der Tourist
nordlenggries eine Autostunde südlich
von München hierher kommen Paraglider
und Wanderer und Monat für Monat auch
immer mehr Flüchtlinge
206 Menschen sind bereits hier bei etwa
10.000 Einwohnern die geflüchteten
werden vom Land Bayern auf die
Landkreise verteilt die Gemeinden müssen
sie unterbringen im Rathaus sitzen der
Bürgermeister und der Landrat beisammen
und wissen inzwischen nicht mehr wie sie
das machen sollen wir bekommen pro Monat
zwei Busse mit Flüchtlingen wir nehmen
die in eine Turnhalle auf schauen wo sie
dazu passen aber dann kommt die
schwierige Frage wo sind die dauerhaften
Unterbringungen und die haben mir nicht
mehr
die Gemeinden auch nicht mehr vorhanden
die Unterkünfte haben mehr oder weniger
einzelne Plätze voll
ausgebucht oder belegt und es fehlt
hinten vorne an dem Plätzen
Wohnraum ist ohnehin knapp in Lengries
die Münchner Wohnungsnot strahlt bis
hierher wie kann man geflüchtete
unterbringen wenn ich den Wohncontainern
es ist fast nichts zum finden weil alles
ja überfüllt ist und die von München
nach links drücken hat als
landschaftlicheres viele suchen eine
Wohnung ich meine wir suchen auch was
Größeres finden nicht wirklich was was
bezahlbar wäre die Sozialwohnungen hat
man ja verkauft all die letzten 20 Jahre
um
Profit zu schlagen und hat sie günstig
hergegeben und jetzt haben wir halt
keine mehr und es ist jetzt das Resultat
davon und auch Kitaplätze sind knapp die
Wartezeiten lang ein altes Problem dass
durch die Kinder von geflüchteten noch
verschärft wird weil die ähm die
gleichen Voraussetzungen oder die
gleiche das gleiche Recht bekommen wie
wir jetzt die sind in der Warteschleife
genauso dran wie wir auch ja aber
letztendlich finde ich wenn äh
geflüchtete Mama mit Ihrem Kind mit dem
Boot daher flüchtet und sich irgendwie
versucht der neue Heimat oder irgendwie
irgendwas Neues zu erschaffen haben die
finde ich genauso recht wie jeder andere
ja
hinzu kommt noch ein weiteres Problem
immer weniger Menschen wollen sich
sozial für geflüchtete engagieren das
hat auch Kfz-Meister Stöckener
beobachtet wir wenden aber die
freiwillig macht haben
einfach am Ende als Problem ist ja schon
fünf bis Sechseck gehabt und jetzt sind
wir 30 funktioniert nicht
es braucht eben mehr als Wohncontainer
damit Integration so gelingen kann wie
bei Fillmore